evening from Buckingham Palace I'm
Trevor Phillips and welcome to a Sky
News Royal special on the death of the
queen
coming up in the next hour
[Music]
the making of a monarch King Charles is
confirmed at an ancient ceremony the
accession council televised for the very
first time
in carrying out the heavy task that has
been laid upon me
and to which I now dedicate what remains
to me of my life
I pray for the guidance and help of
almighty God
[Music]
the most senior figures in the country
including every living prime minister
[Music]
gun salutes rang out across the United
Kingdom in honor of the new king
Buckingham Palace confirms that the
Queen's State funeral will be held on
Monday September the 19th with a day
declared a bank holiday
a united front the Prince of Wales pays
tribute to his grandmother and makes a
surprise appearance in Windsor alongside
Princess Catherine Prince Harry and
Megan
[Music]
and from pop art to punk
we'll look at how the queen became a
cultural icon
[Music]
good evening from Buckingham Palace and
welcome to this special program on the
death of the queen
it would be easy to underestimate what
has taken place today
it used to be said by courtiers that
showing the inner workings of the
monarchy would be unwise letting the
daylight in on the magic might destroy
the Mystique
well the new king is already testing
that belief to the utmost today started
with live TV coverage of a ceremony
never previously seen by the outside
world
it ended with a king his Queen consort
The Prince and Princess of Wales and the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex on Royal
Walkabout pressing the flesh literally
embracing their people on the streets of
winter and here outside Buckingham
Palace
there's never been a day like it this
perhaps is a sign of what is to come
with our first report our Royal
correspondent Rhiannon Mills has more on
the proclamation of the king
it was ancient pageantry viewed through
a 21st century lens
[Music]
ritual it was last seen 70 years ago
then marking the start and now the end
of the second Elizabethan age
with one voice and consent of tongue and
heart
publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George Is Now by The Death of our late
Sovereign of happy memory
become our only lawful and rightful
leads Lord Charles III
as politicians past and present of all
political Persuasions including every
former living prime minister gathered
inside Saint James's Palace
the privy council at first assembling
without the new king but with his wife
and son among them as privy councilors
to acknowledge formerly the change of
rain
by the grace of God of the United
Kingdom of Great Britain and Northern
Ireland and of his other Realms and
territories
King head of the Commonwealth
defender of the faith God saved the king
moved into the throne room they were
finally joined by King Charles his Heir
and queen consort close by as we were
all able to witness a moment never seen
before a monarch holding his first privy
council meeting personally declaring his
intention to serve
my lords ladies and gentlemen
it is my most sorrowful duty to announce
to you the death of my beloved mother
the queen
I know how deeply you
the entire nation
and I think I may say the whole world
sympathize with me in the irreparable
loss we've all suffered
my mother's Reign was unequaled in its
duration
its dedication and its devotion
even as we grieve we give thanks for
this most faithful life
I am deeply aware of this great
inheritance
and the duties and heavy
responsibilities of sovereignty which
have now passed to me
in taking up these responsibilities
I shall strive to follow the inspiring
example I have been set
and in carrying out the heavy task that
has been laid upon me
and to which I now dedicate what remains
to me of my life
I pray for the guidance and help of
almighty God
it's the personal touches his family
around him The Inkwell on the table
given to him as a gift by Prince William
and Prince Harry
a reminder this is a time of mourning
a solemn occasion for all involved
members of the new cabinet and the
current prime minister and
representatives of the Commonwealth it
was poignant because people were
recognizing how much the Her Majesty the
queen had given us but also welcoming
the new king and for the new King
Charles to make those constitutional
declarations in such a sober and
profound way I think was moving for
everyone and it is a moment I'm sure no
one in that room will ever forget
[Music]
the ceremony in essence is one of
welcome and Fanfare the crowds quickly
adapting to a new national anthem
and going further in their appreciation
three chairs for his majesty the king
hip hip
echoed in the city of London as the
second Proclamation was read on the
steps of the royal Exchange
God Save the King
in the coming days it will be repeated
across the United Kingdom
for now Buckingham Palace Remains the
focal point at times people being turned
away because the crowds were too deep
barriers now in place all along the mall
but behind them a king who wants to be
seen who wants us to understand what
we're now witnessing is like us he's
quickly had to adjust
Ronald Mills Sky News at St James's
Palace
joining me throughout this hour is Lord
woolly Simon to his friends principal of
homerton College Cambridge Simon you've
just come from uh Palace of Westminster
where uh the MPS and members of the
Lords have been sharing their memories
of her majesty uh what is the atmosphere
in there like it was an incredible time
to be in that that space that many Lords
and Ladies paying tribute to to her
majesty the queen and at the end we took
another to the new King speech after
speech was laying bare the the selfless
public duty that this this queen this
role model this figurehead has shown not
just here in in the in the UK but across
the world so it's been an extraordinary
day you spoke to yourself tonight I did
I did how many did you have to say well
I had to say about my experience right
across the road there at uh at
Buckingham Palace three years ago
actually today or almost today when I
was knighted and knighted by a match to
the queen and I I took my son there and
I was as nervous as hell I mean who
wouldn't be right on such a big occasion
but she lent him to me she made me feel
comfortable we started chatting and in
the end joking
and when I came back to my son my son
leaned into me and he said Dad Dad you
made the queen laugh what did you say
and I said I can't tell you son it's a
secret yeah I was just gonna I was just
gonna ask you that I could share the
joke but I know you can't but Betty's
speeches many speeches you know personal
uh General
extremely moving and a lot of a lot of
the peers what we're talking about that
we need to I guess take a leaf Out Of
Her Majesty's book when it comes to
selfless public duty the Public Services
sacrifice she said in that documentary I
think one of the interesting things that
we've seen the last 48 hours has been
both from the Royal Family itself
particularly the king but also from
those who knew the Queen the experience
has been very personal and people have
given tributes that Mrs May told a joke
by the million do you think this is a
sign of a sort of closeness perhaps to
the royal family that people didn't
quite expect well it's great to see I
mean when I walked down and I saw
families with their kids I saw one one
parent sent to the child do you know the
queen was when she died and the charge
said 90 96 how many years did she Reign
she said 70. she was six years of age
you know this is a nation coming
together in in sorrow in grief but
actually United
United United to say this was our great
Monarch and what it means to be British
what it means to be part of the
Commonwealth I'm really pleased I'm
really pleased that that a nation has
come together in this way not only to
celebrate the life of a great human
being
but also to celebrate the incoming of
our of our new king a good man uh oh I
think we'll reign in in a similar uh I
guess inclusive way as the queen did
well that's an interesting point because
actually
um what we've seen today starting with
the accession council televised for the
first time so that people the people
who've never seen this before had it
right there live and the Walkabout this
afternoon do you think this is uh the
development of a style of course the
queen was the first to do the Walkabout
Back in 1970 I think
um but are we seeing a development of
that openness well I think so I mean
look the king will do things his way and
I've been lucky enough to to work with
him to collaborate with him and I've
seen what a what a human being he is
he's very personable he likes to listen
he likes he likes to be tactile and and
I think that if he can govern in that
way as head of state and people warm to
it that I think people will get another
view a more Fuller view of our King then
often you read in the newspapers
I think just very briefly that um
the new Prince of Wales will essentially
be taking up some of uh his duties I do
hope so I mean look I've been involved
in in some of the the bodies that is
that the prince was now King that the
prince's Tross was involved with and
they are super important for example the
prince's trust has up to over two
million young young men and women often
from black Asian minority ethnic
communities it's so important though
it's a pathway for them to develop I I
hope that Prince William takes that
baton and runs with it Simon thank you
very much for the moment okay uh we've
talked a bit already about the different
tone today uh we know and we've seen
from uh some of the coverage of the last
couple of days but the queen with the
first TV documentary uh Prince Philip
the first Royal to be interviewed on
television and of course the invention
of the royal Walkabout has did something
extraordinary to bring the mystery of
the monarchy down to the ground down to
the people and she it is estimated that
about a third of the British people have
actually seen or met her so perhaps what
we've seen today is the development of
that uh but to talk a little bit more
about what we've seen I'm going to turn
now to our correspondent Laura bundock
uh Laura
um new style today
I think so I mean the day started as
perhaps you might have expected this
very ceremonial event this ancient this
Arcane this traditional thing none of us
has seen before mostly because it's
never been televised before but in some
ways very inaccessible as well and then
of course after that formality you have
the absolute accessibility of everything
so we saw the new king make his way from
the palace along the mouth stopping to
then go out and greet people in person
and then perhaps of all an even bigger
surprise a walkabout in Windsor not just
the new Prince and Princess of Wales but
a royal Source said their request the
sussexes as well so you see for the
first time since 2020 for years now two
Royal Brothers brought together and the
late queen always spoke about her soft
power and I think perhaps here it is we
see Prince this is William Princess
Prince Harry we know of their Rift it's
been playing out so publicly and yet the
four of them them and their their wives
case and Megan walking in Windsor to go
and meet the crowds it was quite a
moment is it the healing of that
relationship we don't know but it
certainly was an incredible moment and
again having had the huge ceremony at
the beginning of the day this is the
other side to the royal family I think
the new king very keen to present you
know his replacement as Prince of Wales
the new Princess of Wales and the two
brothers as well as site perhaps we had
not expected to see I thought it was
very striking the shot of the four of
them walking out of the gates at Windsor
going to inspect the flowers and I was
thinking
we know that that what nobody knows
exactly what's happened behind closed
doors but we know that these two
operations have for quite a long time
been uh working separately and it
striked me that um
Her Majesty had a rather uh particular
capability of rather softly exercising
steel and I just wondered whether her
son what we saw today was her son's
first exercise as King in essentially
saying I really am not bothered what
goes on between you but you have a
responsibility to the country get out
there
we will never know what is said Behind
Closed Palace doors but what we do know
is certainly when the sussexes arrived
in England there was no expectation they
would meet any member of the royal
family but clearly the events of this
week have changed all that to the extent
they have changed that we don't know but
you would like to think perhaps that the
new king as he tries to present himself
as the future he tries to show the
continuity of the monarchy that he will
make it a meaningful role that he will
speak to the people that he will
understand their needs as he begins this
new Reign is trying to involve his
family as much as possible how much of
the family will be involved as we know
the sussexes have no official Royal role
we don't know yet but certainly the
pictures I think are historic images
from the pageantry at the start of the
day to this relaxed moment and the
bringing together of Two Brothers we did
not expect to see side by side in this
way and perhaps that was the signal that
he gave in his address yesterday when he
said in really I think affectionate
terms that you could see the father in
him that he expressed his love for Harry
and Megan and I wonder if that might
have been the opening to say
you may not do the official you may not
be part of the firm but you can
certainly play a role in what we do as a
country well it was a pivotal speech
yesterday it was obviously the tribute
to his late mother but it was very much
him setting out giving us a glance a
glimpse into what his monarchy will look
like the kind of monarchy will be he
referenced with those fitting and very
touching words to the queen consort to
Camilla to The Prince and new Prince and
Princess of Wales but he didn't leave
out Megan and Harriet and you do Wonder
did that have anything to do with the
the Olive Branch request that the Prince
of Wales made to his brother to join him
today in Windsor
thank you Laura well Buckingham Palace
have released details of key moments in
the coming days
the state funeral for the queen will be
held on Monday the 19th of September at
11 A.M at Westminster Abbey
tomorrow Sunday the 11th the Queen's
coffin will leave Balmoral for Hollywood
Palace at 10 A.M
further Proclamation will be read in
Scotland Wales and Northern Ireland
devolved parliaments
on Monday the 12th of September the king
will deliver a speech at Westminster
Hall
before he travels to Edinburgh the
Queen's coffin will be taken to Saint
Charles Cathedral
the procession leaves Hollywood at 2 35
pm and the service takes place at the
Cathedral at 3 pm
the king will travel to Northern Ireland
on Tuesday the 13th the Queen's coffin
will be flown to London to rest at
Buckingham Palace in the throne room
where it will be dressed with a crown
orb and scepter
on Wednesday the 14th of September the
Queen's coffin will be taken in
procession from Buckingham Palace to the
Palace of Westminster
the Covenant is then moved to
Westminster hall for lying in state and
lying in state will last four full days
on Friday the 16th the king will travel
to Wales
and on Monday the 19th the state funeral
takes place and Laura is still with me
Laura is this much as expected
I think so I mean there is there is no
doubt that the queen herself would have
had a big part in the planning on award
list we know the planning has has been
taking place for many many years now but
we're getting the details now so we know
the exact movements both of her coffin
and also of the king himself too as he
wants to move around the rest of the
United Kingdom to to visit all the
different nations and so starting in
Scotland then moving to Northern Ireland
and Wales on Friday very much carrying
on with the official duties but as much
as possible meeting people who he knows
sharing his grief who are mourning with
him as well but I think a lot of eyes
will now be on the moment from Wednesday
when the Queen's coffin will be lying in
state and members of the public I'm sure
many of the people here will be allowed
the chance to file past her coffin and
pay in person their respects and if you
judge the cues from her late father's
funeral when he was lying in state
accusing enormous the same for the queen
mother as well and I'm you would expect
the cues will stretch back I think it
will be remarkable scenes and then of
course a funeral perhaps the like of
which we've never seen before on Monday
not just the dignitaries and that but
the number of people I think who will
want to be there in some way to watch
the final farewell to the late Queen I
think it'll be it'll be a remarkable
event won't it I mean I think the queen
mother had uh something like 300 000
people who filed past her um coffin and
I expect we will see
a number possibly a multiple of that for
the queen they're not just here but
around the world you know we have the
internet now and the numbers will be
millions and millions from here to every
part of the world I imagine wanting to
watch and witness what is a moment in
history Laura thank you very much indeed
wrexham in North Wales was due to be
celebrating its recent Award of City
status as part of the Queen's Platinum
Jubilee celebrations earlier this year
instead tonight it's residents are
coming to terms with the death of the
Monarch and the beginning of a new era
of Royal rule
Katarina vitotsi has been looking at how
one Community has been dealing with a
new Royal reality
[Music]
xim as spells rang out
Charles's accession inside a model of
the late Queen's crown came down
there was meant to be a party here today
to Mark wrexham getting City status
celebrations now obviously postponed
the late Queen granted City status and
this was the day when we were going to
have the formal official celebration to
Market so we had a really big service
involved so at this point on the
Saturday morning we were expecting the
place to be sort of full of people and
full of bustle what's the mood been like
over the last few days
it's just been a sort of yeah almost a
sense of unreality that we can't quite
take it in because she's been such a
constant for the whole of our lives
really
awesome has a royal pedigree
Street hasn't always been kind to the
place itself at wrexham they started a
tour of a thoroughly depressed area
where the old heavy Industries have
failed and a desperate attempt is being
made to attract new companies
specifically in Light Industry
things have been changing pretty fast
here in wrexham the town becoming a city
its football team getting taken over by
Hollywood actor Ryan Reynolds and now
wrexham and indeed the whole of Wales
has got a new prince and princess
Alison Williams met Princess Diana here
in 1991 and now welcomes her son Prince
William and his wife taking on the role
I think William and Kate are amazing I
think they will make a brilliant Prince
Princess of Wales it's nice that they
lived here for so long it means that
they're interested and they understand
more about Wales the new Prince and
Princess of Wales also bring with them
this
a way of operating online that's as
slick as in real life
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck for tonight but in a moment
where the monarchy is looking to its
future for some even these social media
Savvy younger Royals feel somewhat
distant on their Instagram they post all
these pretty things they're starting the
other we don't get to see that it would
be impossible for them to feel relatable
to anyone in our generation at the very
least anyway because of the struggles
we're having with the inflation and like
living crisis you know they don't have
to deal with that as much as a slot
that's what we all want as a country we
want them to bring
the UK into the new generation and be
more relatable he's got to look back to
his grandfather and his Father's
Footsteps for instance you've got the
Duke of Edinburgh award and then the
prince's trust award
in the moment the queen died Royal rolls
shifted titles changed but the
responsibility remains to engage the
public and preserve a legacy
Catherine evertotsi Sky News in wrexham
the queen was revered around the world
but she always had a special place in
her heart a soft spot for the
Commonwealth which she saw grow from
just a few former colonies to a club of
56 Nations some of which were never part
of the British Empire
and many people from those countries
including my own family made the UK
their home during her reign
Skye's Lisa Holland has been speaking to
Commonwealth communities
we all call you Grandma yes in South
London friends and family call Louise
the queen of Brixton not just because
she's a great great grandmother who
fostered more than 20 children but at 96
years of age she was born on exactly the
same day as Queen Elizabeth II they call
you the queen of Brixton I hear yes yes
yes
when I had burnt bit it comes up at that
time it is the Queen birthday and from
being tall but feeling good Louise came
to Britain as part of the Windrush
generation I shall strive to follow
the inspiring example I have been set
but has she watched the proclamation of
a new king she recalled the late Queen
visiting Jamaica in the 1950s
to everyone I will be back
in Multicultural Brixton scratched the
surface and it's easy to find people
who've made their home here with fond
memories of the Queen's Decades of
global Commonwealth tours
when I was at school when I remember the
helicopter land at the back of the
school and Sierra from that um now is
not the time for morning now is the time
to celebrate the lady Life to Live our
life to the max she still would make
everyone feel like
part of the Commonwealth part of brick
you know so I just think about the
world's a poorer place without what's
also clear is just how significant the
Queen's Global influence and standing
was in so many countries around the
world there's no green anywhere else
like only United Kingdom in this fabric
shop we met Bill Al who said it was
watching the queen from a young age
which inspired him to want to move to
the UK from India nearly 20 years ago we
always heard about the news like Queen
sometimes picture come in on the
newspaper what's he done like Michael
who grew up in Ghana says the Queen's
Legacy will live on absolutely very
strong brand now we've got a king she
might probably follow the same footstep
that the mom left behind
Britain's new king already has the Good
Will of those who revered his mother to
help build his own future as Monarch
Lisa Holland Sky News South London
it's a rather striking thing isn't it
Simon that um when you go I know you
travel a lot so you go around the world
when people talk about the queen there's
only one person generally speaking that
comes to mind
um how do you think we got to that place
is it just her or is it Britain or our
history right I think I think it's her I
think it's her quiet strength her
humility and when going to these
countries Far and Beyond I think that
she wants to know about them she wants
to know about the people and so they
remember
and and actually the same as with Prince
Charles I've just been in Malaysia and
they were talking about his visit in in
2017. I think the thing is being present
and making every individual feel special
the queen has done it the queen did it
over 70 years and the prince over 50
years it's called Duty and sacrifice and
they both know about it
the um of course for many countries the
relationship with Britain has a
complicated history
um and I know you were in Barbados when
the uh when the king uh went to the
ceremony where they installed then new
head of state and so on now it's a
tricky thing and the queen seemed seemed
to have managed it extraordinarily well
but do you think that the new king is
going to face some extra strains because
we hear talk about this in Australia we
had talked about it all over the
Caribbean that it's time for that
relationship to change well I think he
showed leadership with that I mean he
said to the people of Barbados to Mayor
Motley the president look this is your
choice and the beauty about it is when
you have those adult conversations you
can make that choice some will some
won't but you can remain in the
Commonwealth you can remain
part of the family do business share
culture it's not that I win you lose
it's that we reset in a in a modern
world with a modern Britain and I
thought he was Brave because I'm sure
that there were detractors waiting for
him to slip up but he didn't and uh it's
no surprise to me that this morning the
the Beijing prime minister mayor Motley
pay tribute paid tribute to him with his
views about the climate change and which
is held for many decades but also his
vision for disadvantaged young people
and making sure that they have a pathway
Trevor I heard that and um I I thought
that the interesting thing was that uh
in spite of the fact that basically a
few months ago Barbados said thank you
very much how do you had enough we've
got our own a head of state um it was a
rather warm tribute yeah do you think
that the vehicle which I think the Queen
the late queen always thought of as the
future the Commonwealth
um is right now going to be a priority
for the new king I think so because it
binds us all together and so you know we
we reset we change the historical Legacy
of the enslavement of Africans and and
colonialism I mean you know that has to
be feathered and this is part of that
process what you get after that is up to
us and now we negotiate it but it has to
be inclusive it has to be respectful I
think the the king now is well placed
not least because of the backstory you
know he's been traveling around the
world he knows all these leaders he
knows their their histories and so I
think if we have adult conversations we
can get to we can get to a positive
Place Trevor what do you think um the
first thing he has to do to send a
signal I guess that this is a new time
uh we are no longer if you like the in
charge of things but we want to be yeah
friends and partners to be honest with
you I think he's been doing that
and and people and people who know him
and the countries that have been to will
also recognize that too now how fast
that moves and how it moves is between
is between the countries and what their
people want and then negotiating them uh
with with with the new king
he above all knows that our nation has
to let go of that of that old God
okay Lord Willie thank you very much
indeed
let's reflect on today's events now with
Margaret McMillan the distinguished
Emeritus professor of international
history at Oxford University who joined
us now I think from Toronto
uh good evening uh Professor McMillan um
I I understand that Canada is already
um got out of the blocks and has
declared uh the new king king of Canada
is that correct
it is I think and I mean it is but
Canada has a strong relationship with
the monarchy
um we see it I think as a symbol of
stability we still have a governor
general after all and there seems to be
very little will to change that
do you think that um the that
relationship is uh stable for the future
and many people say that uh in fact you
know people have been writing in the
newspapers today that we are about to
face a reckoning which has been delayed
by the personality and the respect and
admiration in which the late Queen was
held but we're now going to have to face
a reality in which other countries
Australia Canada Caribbean countries
some African countries uh want to reset
that relationship are you getting any
sign of that in Canada
in Canada there's no strong Republican
movement occasionally we get a few
flurries I think we've been so focused
on our own internal constitutional
issues that we haven't really had time
to think about the monarchy all that
much and I think also a lot of Canadians
like their monarchy as a symbol that
we're not the United States and when you
live next door to a great big Power are
there somewhere you like to distinguish
yourselves in some way I don't I think
there's been a reset anyway and there's
always been a discussion of the
Commonwealth of what it should be I
think that the death of the queen and
the accession of King Charles III will
see that conversation continuing but I
don't expect it to be a decisive moment
and as Lord woolly was saying different
countries will make their own decisions
about where they want to go with this
there's of course a a constitutional
issue uh always the governor general of
course is uh the the representative of
the crown in Canada
um there is always an issue about the
powers and whether there is in uh
intervention or not uh do Canadians do
think really just see the Monarch as a
symbol of a historical link and as if
you like a cultural uh symbol that tells
people as you say we are not America
or is there more to it than that
I don't think so the um you know for
since since the second world war
Governors General have been appointed on
the recommendation of the Canadian
government so the British government has
not interfered at all and we now run
over on the first we have been running
our own Affairs for a great many years
now I think people here have seen the
queen actually very much as people in
other parts of the world including the
United States have seen the queen as
someone who exemplified good solid
qualities I mean the words that keep
coming out dignity
um decisiveness doing her job
um not complaining these are the sorts
of things that have been said in the
American Media they're being said around
the world and so I think Canadians share
that view is is here as an adorable
person
um an icon if you like of the ways in
which we'd like to see heads of state
behave and someone who stood somehow
above Party politics and so I think for
Canadians the queen was as important as
a symbol of that type of behavior and a
symbol of those values as she was of any
relationship with Britain
can we talk a little bit more about if
you like the the broad role whether it's
cultural or constitutional of monarchy
um there is a point of view that says
that uh in the 21st century uh where the
spread of democracy with the practice of
uh liberal democracy the maturity of
parliamentary democracies it is in some
way anachronistic
what do you think in countries like
United Kingdom that Canada many of the
commonwealth countries that share a
history what do you think that the con
continuing
practical valuable role of monarchy
might be
monarchy in as the way it's evolved I
think and I'm thinking of the British
Monarchy in particular can represent
something that represents all the people
that stands above the political Fray
that reminds us that we are part of one
community and I think that in itself is
valuable in other types of democracies
in republics for example the head of
state is always a member of a party
always always has a political position
and sometimes that works very well
sometimes you get presidents in the
United States for example who are very
divisive who divide up Americans against
each other and I think I can't imagine
who you're referring to Professor
McMillan oh I'm very careful I'm very
careful so I can look southwards very
easily from where I am at the moment but
you know know I think I think there is
something of value in someone who says
look I'm here for all the people I I
represent a sort of continuity I don't
have any power the British monarch
doesn't have significant power as as the
Monarch once used to have but does
represent that sort of continuity and
represents the hope that we can act
actually on occasion see ourselves as
part of one community
there's another
um point of view about this and I think
it came up rather recently in Canada
which is that of course the relationship
is one that is better that is embedded
deeply in history and not not all of
that history is one that every country
wants to remember uh in the Caribbean uh
part of that history is slavery in uh
Africa part of that uh history is the
worst part elements of colonialism Civil
War uh violent struggles for
Independence and in Canada of course
there is the history perhaps of the
treatment of uh First Nation people
how do you think that this Monarch is
going to be able to deal with those
issues which I think perhaps are much
more prevalent much more present in the
public mind than they might have been in
her mother's time
it's important isn't it to to look at
our past and all its complexity and not
try and gloss over things that were done
I think all I can say there is that we
have to confront things that were done
and sometimes those were done in the
name of the British crown sometimes they
were done by the locals not necessarily
in the name of the crown and quite often
there was objection to the ways in which
the indigenous were being treated for
example in Australia and in Canada from
the British authorities so I think we
have to accept the past in all its
complexity we can't gloss over what
happened in the past but I think we also
have to accept that individuals
countries institutions change and what
we have to do is try and deal with the
Deep scars that have been left at the
past and try and continue to try and
build communities that actually work and
I don't see the fact that the crown or
indeed many institutions in Britain and
in Canada were responsible for the bad
treatment of some of their their fellow
citizens or fellow subjects should make
us throw the whole lot out um you know I
tend to be not a revolutionary on that I
think you're better trying to amend what
you have and improve of it then scrap
everything and start again
finally I may just ask you quickly about
what if you like a personal uh issue for
uh Canada your prime minister Mr Trudeau
um seemed very emotional when he
responded uh on Thursday I think it was
to the death of uh her majesty the queen
and of course she had known his father
as prime minister
um what do you think that meant to him
uh that this person who he seemed to
have the deepest respect for and as a
leader uh what do you think that would
have meant to him
I can't speculate on what he was
thinking or feeling but perhaps
something like a lot of us have been
feeling that when someone well known
dies and the queen is known around the
world and was known around the world
where someone of that statue dies I
think we often all stop and reflect
about our own parents dying or people
that we love dying that it makes us
remember the transitoriness of life and
and that people you love do disappear
from the scene and so who knows but
perhaps he was thinking of that um his
father died he's he's suffered losses in
his life and the Queen's death I think
has been a moment for reflection and and
you know as I say I can't speak for him
but I'm wondering if that is part of it
certainly I know a lot of people I know
are saying that it makes you think again
of those you've lost
uh Professor McMillan I think that's a
very very important and
uh significant thought to end on thank
you very much indeed for your time
thank you
princess Elizabeth she then was was in
Kenya when she learned from her husband
the devastating news that her father
George VI had died and she had become
Queen
she attended ascended to the throne on
the steps of the State House in Nairobi
unusually following a proclamation in
the Kenyan capital
that Proclamation is similar to those
which have taken place across the
Commonwealth today for her son Charles
III
Aleister bunkel sent this report from
Nairobi on the Queens Kenya connection
is where the reign of Queen Elizabeth
started but her death has stirred mixed
emotions for a country that didn't
always have the easiest relationship
with the late model
in 1952 the then princess Elizabeth was
on a royal visit with her new husband
Prince Philip her trip was cut short
when her father King George VI
unexpectedly died the young princess
became Queen whilst on Kenyan land a
date that many still fondly remember in
nairobi's rail Museum the Queen's Royal
visits are celebrated
so when she visited Kenya in 1983 she
used the Royal trade on her way to
nanyuki you've got er there Elizabeth
Regina
why is it important to
preserve this
we are happy because
history was made in Kenya during that
time and we are glad to be part of that
history
but there is another history Britain's
Colonial rule the British cracked down
on the Mao Mao Uprising killed an
estimated 11
000 Kenyans and many held the queen as
Britain's head of state responsible
Kenya was colonized by by the British
and being colonized by the British
people have lost their fathers they have
lost their grandparents here fighting
for Independence fighting for
independence from the colonies so again
when this is a colonizer there are
people who that is the feeling they have
the association with the queen has also
had some positives yes yes there are
positives I mean the colonization also
brought positive things but again
there's the negativity bit of the losses
that Kenya as a people went through
signs of British colonial history and
the resentment of it are unavoidable in
Nairobi
the city's main road was named princess
Elizabeth Highway when it opened but
since renamed Freedom Road after
Independence
time has healed only so much here King
Charles ascended to the throne replacing
the mother this in itself marks a new
beginning I don't think
a great fraction of Kenyans who look at
it like that the more critical ones will
remain critical will still continue to
pose their hard and uncomfortable
questions and will demand economic
Justice political Justice and
reparations
Britain and Kenya share a past and a
future both are members of the
Commonwealth
but a new king won't necessarily be a
new beginning
Alistair bunker Sky News in Nairobi
let's take a moment with that theme the
reaction to the Queen's death in the
Commonwealth
despite a growing Republican movement in
Australia her death has overwhelmingly
been met with public sorrow
Kai's Sky's cordilla Lynch report from
Sydney on Australia's response
[Music]
it is a generation absorbing the impact
of an era defining monarch
where the Queen Once walked her son must
now follow and here in Australia it is a
turning point we just loved her we just
loved it the older we got the more we
could relate to her because she felt
like she was just always there for us
I'm just like a lot of others older
Australians we're just grieving because
she was the queen of Australia a lot of
people that's lost a lot of people it
felt like the queen was almost
um
Immortal at some point you know she uh
she's lived a long time and yeah I mean
even though she um was quite old when
she passed it still came as a shock
she was the first reigning monarch to
visit these Shores
[Music]
it was 1954 she stayed for 58 days and
left a population Spellbound I want to
tell you all how happy I am to be
amongst you
and how much I look forward to my
journey through Australia such Outburst
of spontaneous affection
well she loves this country she loved
this country I should say she'd been
here 16 times and you don't do that if
you don't like the place and she came
back again and again and again and she
found the same thing again and again
again warmth affection I think she
really admired the resilience of
Australians who work and live off the
land here it's very nice to see you in
Morrison at my
nerves she had he says a Regal humility
that's why you know it's a cliche we'll
never see a like again but
we won't where do you see that
relationship with the crown going there
does remain a strong connection and an
appreciation I mean our our success in
Australia is in no small part due to the
stability of our democracy of our
constitutional system and the crown sits
at the heart of that
but it has already had a referendum on
becoming a republic and that
conversation could reanimate
whatever debate has and may yet rage
around Australia's relationship with the
monarchy this is being recognized as a
period of remembrance and respect and in
a febrile world that feels strikingly
rare
their love for the institution has waned
over time but not their love for the
queen that appears enduring
Sky News Sydney Australia
with the passing of her majesty the
queen some sporting events were canceled
today as a mark of respect
however some did go ahead with those
present taking the opportunity to pay
tribute to the late Queen
our Sports correspondent Rob Harris has
been looking at some of those sporting
tributes
confusion to the nation across the
Commonwealth and around the world
cricket returning with solemnity and
silence
players and fans bonded by sport uniting
at the oval to mournemonic
[Music]
a rendition of God Save the King the
first broadcaster at a sporting event
since the accession of Charles before
the delayed start of England's test
against South Africa Cricket resuming
while some other sports remained
suspended in Britain
the powerful tributes here at the oval
showed why Cricket leaders wanted their
sport to resume to honor they said the
life and service of the queen she wants
to use her Christmas broadcast to talk
about the power of sports in being able
to bring people together and we've seen
here just how that can take place
I personally wouldn't have wanted to
play I'd wanted two or three days just
to reflect and think about
um all the wonderful things she's done
yeah I can also understand the thinking
about people coming together with sport
it's a fine line and I suppose really at
the end of the day you do what you
think's best football was the main sport
choosing to shut down food destined for
premier league stadiums like Liverpool
donated to food banks a decision is yet
to be taken on whether domestic football
is played next weekend before the
Queen's funeral
in golf play at the PGA Championship at
Wentworth was suspended following the
Queen's death on Thursday
it restarted on Saturday after the
government left it at the discretion of
each sport whether to hold events
Rugby Union had split decisions across
the United Kingdom with the games only
in England this weekend horse racing the
sporting passion of Queen Elizabeth that
once gave her success in the Gold Cup at
Ascot resumes with the saint Ledger on
Sunday
The Cricket in London those no longer
able to play sport this weekend taking
the chance to pay respect
[Applause]
[Music]
when kind of everyone just went silent
and that was unprompted it was uh yeah
it was quite special a bit emotional I
got a little bit choked up I have to
admits I'm a monarchist so I've been
brought up you know I believe and um I
thought it's really moving actually yes
in a nation grieving sport bringing
people together to express condolences
and gratitude to the Queen's service and
Reign Rob Harris Sky News the oval
of correspondent Laura bundock is here
with me once again Laura um somebody
rather than candy said today they know
that there's continuity because today
there was an England batting collapse
but more broadly
um I think sporting fixtures uh it
showed that there's very deep feeling in
the country and I think we're seeing
that in the turnout here and at winter
aren't we I think so and what I think is
striking being stood here outside
Buckingham Palace not just the silence
but the size of the crowd and the fact
that here we are at this time of night
and that the people are still coming
they're accused of people walking as I
say quietly peacefully many of them
carrying flowers and a lot of those
flowers are now being moved and the size
of that mound of flowers is quite
something it is huge and we saw in
Windsor as well with that remarkable
impromptu Walkabout a walk about we did
not expect to see not just the prince
and princess of Wales but of course that
their invitation uh Harry and Megan the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex as well we
are seeing deep crowds there and I think
you notice as well the crowds ranging in
age it's not perhaps the sort of crowd
you would expect at a royal event I was
here for the Jubilee and certainly I
think you would recognize the crowd
there but here I feel it is a wider
range of people and the new king spoke
of that in his speech yesterday that
very public is important first address
really to the nation talking about his
recognition of the backgrounds and
beliefs and the range of that and I
think that is reflected in in the people
who are coming and of course these
crowds will grow particularly once the
Queen's coffin arrives back in London um
for the lying in state where you are
imagining thousands and thousands and
thousands will want to turn up to file
past I mean it's interesting I mean one
thing that seems clear is that there's
going to be going on for nine or ten
days and you would expect
if you like the intensity to drop but
there's no sign of that at the moment
absolutely the opposite I think I was
struck late last night walking through
the parks how many people were still
here and again tonight this crowd is
moving and it is moving in one direction
towards the palace and as I say in
Windsor you saw on the long walk the Hue
the Deep crowds there and you can only
imagine that these crowds are going to
grow and grow crescendoing towards
Monday week when of course the big state
funeral will take place and you'd expect
many people here will want to be as
close as they can or in the vicinity of
such an occasion well I suspect you and
I will be in this vicinity a lot over
the next week and a bit Laura thank you
very much and indeed
now over the course of her Reign the
queen became perhaps the most
photographed person ever to have lived
and Her Image used in everything from
pop art to punk Katie Spencer has been
looking at the life of a cultural icon
he was the most portrayed woman in the
world her face in profile ubiquitous Her
Image at the core of British culture
groundbreaking the first ever to be
televised watched by 27 million it was
the premiere of sorts for the lifelong
pivotal role she'd play in maintaining
the Allure of brand Britain
I remember when I was a little girl a
little teenager when she was engaged to
Prince Philip who was about the best
looking man in the world I mean
everybody at school had a crush on him
and I kept scrapbook to the queen
everything that was in the papers of the
magazines I cut out and it was um
princess Elizabeth's wedding and she was
a fairy tale princess she really was she
was gorgeous he had a hand span waist
big wonderful eyes we all just loved her
and decades on record audiences once
again tuned in for her Platinum Jubilee
perhaps
you would like a marmalade sandwich
I always keep one for emergencies
so do I
I keep mine in here
celebrations which brought people back
together following the challenges of the
pandemic
during lockdown of course many binged on
the crown
one of the countless screen portrayals
fueled by the Relentless public
infatuation with this woman
mother
celebrated by our greatest artists from
Lucian Freud to Andy Warhol her
portraits now a huge part of her Legacy
I remember when I when I first
commissioned it was a daunting Prospect
you know the Queen the most portrayed
woman in history I asked if man would
like to rest in between shots that'd be
fine just I was conscious of all the
light onto her so she closed her eyes
and that was the moment it was you know
I didn't go in there to capture that
moment but being so tuned to meditation
at the time you know in that moment of
calmness you know there's a kind of
vibration to it and which we all
resonate at sitting for artists was part
of her cultural duty but she also
inspired some significant unofficial art
an anti-establishment Target epitomized
on the cover of the 1977 sex pistol
single her defaced lightness an easy Act
of rebellion if you enter most West
Indians home at the time they would
probably have a picture of the queen on
a wall as well as a picture of Jesus
while Rock photographer Dennis Morris's
parents admired the queen for his
generation she represented everything he
was rallying against in 1977 when the
punk movement collided with the Queen's
Silver Jubilee He was following the
pistol's provocative Boat Trip on the
Thames at that time the monarchy was
very very strong we were not
particularly like for being Auntie
monarchy in that sense As I Grew Older
and knew more and more about it I have a
very very deep respect for the queen and
my respect for the queen is this that
basically it takes a lot to hold
something like that together in the way
she has over the years so you know for
me big respect for that in that sense
while many British artists have clashed
with the establishment the queen a loyal
supporter of creativity handed out
thousands of honors for services to the
entertainment sector
70 years she was champion of the Arts
for those who embraced her magisterial
Authority or rebelled against it she
inspired her influence over British
culture irrefutable and unique
thank you for everything
that's very kind Katie Spencer Sky News
foreign
that's all for this special program
coming up next is News at 10 with
Jillian Joseph and all of today's
historic developments
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
live from Buckingham Palace
the making of a monarch King Charles is
confirmed as the nation's Sovereign at
an ancient ceremony broadcast to the
public for the very first time
in carrying out